the head of the National Rifle
Association says anti-gun forces are
playing politics with last week's week's
massacre at the Florida High School
courts Mountain Peter Doocy is at the
site of the Conservative Political
Action Conference CPAC at National
Harbor Maryland tonight good evening
Peter
good evening Brett even though we are
just 11 and a half miles away from the
White House the NRA CEO who is a big
supporter of President Trump delivered
remarks about gun control that are a
world apart from the president's
proposed fixes their solution is to make
you all of you less free Wayne LaPierre
the CEO of the NRA did not mince words
warning about what he sees as a
potential post parkland gun grab and now
some people Carr calling for a new list
of anyone anyone who has sought mental
healthcare to deny them their second
Amendment rights the NRA is a presenting
sponsor of CPAC so it has a heavy
presence throughout the Gaylord
Convention Center in Maryland its
officials spent today advocating for
stronger security at schools and
criticizing Democratic lawmakers pushing
for major gun control legislation for
them it's not a safety issue it's a
political issue they care more about
control and more of it their goal is to
eliminate the Second Amendment the next
speaker was vice president pence whose
Parkland remarks included a pledge to
come together later this week when the
president meets with the nation's
governors in our nation's capital will
will make the safety of our nation's
schools and our students our top
national priority pens today's headliner
also laid the foundation for the
strategy that GOP operatives tell Fox is
their best bet to keep the house
criticized Nancy Pelosi you know it
would be a disaster for our cause if
Nancy Pelosi became Speaker of the House
again
but we're not gonna let it happen there
was Russia talk at CPAC Thursday session
in the context of the Kremlin being a
threat to the United States there were
no questions about the special counsels
probe for the White House Counsel Don
Magan who instead used rare public
remarks to explain how he helps
president Trump select judges as rumors
swirl about a potential summertime
Supreme Court retirement what the
president likes are folks who have
demonstrated some sort of courage some
sort of ability to stand strong in the
face of adversity people who you know
when they get on the bench they will not
change and turn into someone else just
as Dwarfs ajiz appointment was saluted
by many of today's speakers who took
turns rattling off president Trump's
accomplishments like reducing
regulations vowing to move the American
Embassy in Israel to Jerusalem and
repealing the individual mandate it's
what led Bill Clinton to call Obamacare
one of the craziest things in the world
about the only time I've ever agreed
with with Bill Clinton about Hillary and
CPAC is not just speeches in a ballroom
the hallways are lined with boots boots
like this one sponsored by conservative
leaning outlets organizers say it is all
about activism training and campaign
management the crowd here skews very
very young and tomorrow they are going
to hear from President Trump right Peter
Doocy at CPAC Peter thanks